well straight racing continues to
frustrate neighbors in different parts
of the valley in fact on monday we
showed you the issues in the far
northeast part of the valley tonight
more homeowners are upset about the
trend happening near them sasha loftis
joining us now live near craig and
cimarron with more on the issues that
some there are facing
denise those who live in this area say
they see and hear people racing up and
down these streets every week like
clockwork they say they want to stop put
to it until someone gets hurt
they're going to get somebody killed
illegal racing on the streets of las
vegas
[Music]
it's an issue many have seen before and
some in the northwest valley say it's
ramping up again and causing concerns
across the community
scott mergle says he deals with the
sound of revving engines and screeching
tires several times a week in his
neighborhood near craig and cimarron
they think nobody is around but there's
so many blind corners on their road
all it takes is one this comes days
after several serious complaints near
buffalo and deer springs and iron
mountain and sky canyon very loud sounds
like they're racing we reached out to
metro police about the status of racing
on our valley streets they gave us this
update wednesday
the lvmpd traffic bureau has identified
several people involved in these
incidents and this is an ongoing
investigation
i don't think they really care if they
kill anybody including themselves scott
says he's happy to hear action is being
taken and he asks anyone involved in
this to choose a better option there's
so many
legal outlets to do it it's just stupid
to do it on their own he also encourages
everyone else to keep your guard up no
matter where you are
now again metro police say this is under
investigation and they have identified
several people involved in these
incidents now if you have any
information that could help police you
are asked to contact metro's traffic
bureau we have more information on our
website 8newsnow.com for now reporting
live tonight sasha loftis 8 news now